think you know just because you if
you're feeling an emotion and you kind
of being like Oh well if I just think
about it then I'll get more sad that's
you pushing the emotion away that
doesn't mean it goes away it's still
there it kind of does for me honestly
like I swear to God it looks like I'm
outside
okay there's like research on this if
you like I've been in situations where
I'm like sad but if you pretend to be
happy long enough like your butt your it
like tricks your brain like to think
make it yeah like they think you're ha
it thinks you're happy but I found like
if I just sit and like complain about my
problems like I I personally have never
found that effective unless it's like
maybe you know some people have like
Secrets or like stuff they've never
talked about for years and need to tell
someone but it's like how long do you
need to do that for to the point where
it almost like it seems like it would
make it worse